bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 18 décembre
merci de nous rejoindre dans filcho
l'émission qui revient sur votre
actualité économique locale on commence
tout de suite avec les titres de cette
édition il y a plus d'un an le centre
commercial des gaâtines était victime
d'un incendie nous sommes retournés sur
place un an après les choses n'ont pas
beaucoup changé clients et commerçants
sont exaspérés par la situation vous
n'avez plus l'idée de cadeau pourtant
noël arrive à grand pas à versaill des
créateurs proposent des produits fait
main une tendance qui revient au bout du
jour enfin notre entreprise de la
semaine est dans l'air du temps
puisqu'elle est le numéro 1 français des
jeux de société à ce modé c'est son nom
et elle ne cesse de se développer dans
notre entretien nous parlerons du projet
Paris Saclay mardi soir une table ronde
a eu lieu à la mairie de voisin le
Bretonneux de nombreux représentants du
projet étaient présents pour échanger
sur ce futur grand pôle d'activité nous
en avons profité pour rencontrer
quelques-uns de ces acteurs et tenter
d'en savoir un peu plus mais avant cela
parlons tout de suite de l'actualité de
la
semaine je vous le disais en titre il y
a un peu plus d'un an le 8 décembre 2013
exactement une partie du centre
commercial des Gatines était ravagé par
un incendie d'origine criminelle un an
après la situation ne s'est pas vraiment
amélioré pour les commerçants encore
présents un reportage réalisé avec
Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude un an après les choses n'ont pas
beaucoup changé au centre commercial des
gaâtines les boutiques ravagées par les
flammes sont toujours en ruine les
clients n'ont pas déserté par solidarité
mais ils regrettent que le lieu soit
presque laissé à l'abandon B c'était
bien pratique ce ce petit ce petit
centre commercial nous rendait quand
même bien service hein puisquil y avait
quand même tout il y avait donc le
casino il y avait le coiffeur bon la
pharmacie elle a eu la chance de
continuer donc oui c'est quelque chose
quand même qu'on utilise et qui met un
peu de vie dans le quartier par sinon il
y a rien d'autre gros dommage pour nous
personnellement non parce qu'on a la
chance d'avoir une voiture et d'être
très mobile mais j'imagine que pour des
gens plus âgés c'est sans doute plus
difficile Vincent Ba a perdu près de la
moitié de son chiffre d'affaires depuis
un an le gérant de la supered vend ses
produits dans ce préfabriqué de 40 m car
la procédure d'enquête les expertises
des assurances sont beaucoup ralenti le
chanti les travaux vont commencer
normalement fin du mois de décembre
normalement mais bon on attend toujours
quoi on est pour l'instant on est
toujours dans les adco heureusement
d'abord pour dépanner la clientèle tout
ça mais on commence à avoir une bonne
perte de clientèle par rapport ça traîne
en longueur les travaux devaient
commencer au début du mois ils ont été
repoussés pour cause de diagnostic
amiante l'attente interminable à
décourager certains commerçants plus de
restaurant ni de coiffeurs seul le
boucher charcutier a pu rapidement se
réinstallé en reprenant les locaux
restés intacts de la boulangerie on a
racheté son fond tout simplement voilà
il y a il y a 8 mois de ça et on a
réussi à ouvrir il y a 6 mois maintenant
ça fait juste 6 mois heureusement pour
nous parce que vu de l'avancée des
travaux je sais pas où on serait
maintenant voilà et ça va ça va à part
bon il y a un peu de de désertion de
clients avec le le peu qu'on est mais
bon faut pas se plainre nous on a réussi
à rebondir c'est l'essentiel mais
malheureusement c'est pas le cas pour
tout le monde he commerçants et
habitants attendent l'installation de
nouveaux commerces pour redynamiser le
centre commercial des gaâtines pour cela
il faudra attendre juin 2015 la date
prévue pour la livraison de nouveaux
bâtiments à moins d'un nouveau
retard pour Noël un vent de créateur
souffle sur versaill jusqu'au 24
décembre une boutique éphémère située au
33 ruill de saint-clou près du quartier
Notre-Dame à versaill réunit une
quinzaine de petites mains de la région
ils exposent et vendent leur propres
création si vous n'avez pas terminé vos
achats de Noël voilà un endroit où vous
pourrez trouver des cadeaux rares et
originaux comme l'ont découvert Patrick
Jacques de dixmud et yolen
t Anne et mariange ont encore quelques
jours pour dénicher leurs cadeaux de
Noël dans cette boutique éphémère à
Versailles le mot d'ordre et le fait
main de quoi dénicher la perle rare
c'est fait souvent avec beaucoup de goût
voilà des petits prix parce que on voit
que c'est les prix sont bien serrés et
puis c'est très très varié très varié
mais surtout unique des bijoux des sacs
de la décoration quelques vêtements une
quinzaine de créateurs principalement de
la région expose et vend ici leurs
produits fabriqués en très petite
quantité avec sa collègue Marie
Charlotte anita est l'organisatrice de
ce qu'elle appelle ce trempelin pour les
petites mains les clients sont au
rendez-vous le fait main est loin d'être
dépassé les gens reviennent vers de
vraie valeur en plus de ça on offre de
la personnalisation il y a des bavoirs
personnalisés il y a des parfums que
vous pouvez créer vous-même il y a du
cartonnage il y a des bijoux voilà tout
ça on peut choisir on peut choisir alors
que des des produits que vous trouvez
partout non venue de rbouiller Anne
Sophie propose ses créations de bijoux
et d'accessoires mode depuis son arrivée
dans cette boutique éphémère le 25
novembre elle a vendu près de 200
produits lors de cette période de fête
elle réalise environ 60 % de son chiffre
d'affaires annuel comme la plupart des
autres créateurs ici Anne Sophie a été
repérée via le site Little Market un
espace web qui permet de présenter et de
vendre ces produits fait mains sur
Internet cette boutique est alors
l'occasion pour les créateurs de se
rencontrer mais aussi d'échanger avec
les clients derrière notre écran on a
très peu d'échanges on a des échanges
c'est c'est c'est moins formel donc du
coup là c'est vrai que ça nous permet
d'échanger et ça nous permet aussi de de
montrer vraiment ce qu'on fait au au au
clients pour une durée d'un mois
d'installation dans cette boutique
chaque créateur débourse environ 500 €.
un vent de créateur est ouvert jusqu'au
24 décembre tous les jours de 10h à 19h
sauf le lundi
matin cette semaine nous faisons
découvrir l'initiative d'un jeune
entrepreneur local Noël Tulin habite à
montinis le breteneux il a décidé de se
lancer dans la livraison mais à vélo son
entreprise s'appelle déivelo un concept
novateur et écologique qu'il espère
développer sur Saint-Quentin en Yveline
je propose de regarder ce reportage
réalisé avec William
l un cycliste pas tout à fait comme les
autres à partir de 18h Noël Tulin ne
sort qu'avec un équipement spécialisé et
son vélo cargo ça c'est une sacoche que
j'ai rajouté par-dessus et sinon on peut
mettre une caisse après c'est un vélo
très résistant mais pourtant
relativement léger on le porte à un bras
un vélo qui lui permet d'effectuer ses
livraisons et de faire jusqu'à 100 km
par jour le premier investissement pour
commencer son activité j'étais coursier
sur Paris et l'entreprise pour laquelle
je travaillais était racheté il
revendait les vélos et c'était au moment
où je souhaitais me lancer sur 50 ans en
Eveline et du coup j'ai fait en sorte
pour le racheter une somme assez modique
je l'ai payé environ 800 € la plus
petite course est facturée 6 € tout
dépend du poids et de la distance Noël
et son propre patron à 26 ans ce grand
passionné de cyclisme et d'écologie
souhaite démocratiser ce concept encore
peu connu en France j'ai un master en
ingénieur juriste en environnement et
j'ai toujours voulu mettre en pratique
dans mon projet professionnel conviction
et en fait j'étais passionné de vélo
pour moi c'était l'un dans l'autre on
peut tout faire à vélo et pourquoi pas
proposer un service de coursier surtout
que 5 quenttin en plus c'est une ville
très cyclable Noël s'est fait accompagn
par la Maison de l'Entreprise et
l'association Susanne Michot après une
étude de marché et la mise en place de
son site internet il conclut son premier
partenariat avec la librairie du canal à
Saint-Quentin pour les fêtes de fin
d'année il livre à domicile les achats
effectués sur le
web ça va ça va nous on a plutôt adhéré
à cette C idé deassocié livre et le vélo
et ce projet écologique nous a plutôt
bien plu au départ donc on a essayé de
mettre en place ça parce que rien
nexistait en fait au PAV donc on partait
d'une feuille blanche donc on s ditz
l'aventure
ensemble Nol des partenariat avec
d'autres commerçants ou de plus grandes
entreprises sur SaintQuentin Enel il se
donne un an pour un premier bilan
d'activité d'ici là vous l'aurez sans
doute déjà
croisé passons maintenant à l'entretien
de la semaine c'est tout de suite
l'objet de notre entretien cette semaine
c'est le cluster Paris sacly le projet
de pôle de compétitivité scientifique et
technologique internationale est né en
2006 il fait partie des projets lié au
Grand Paris il est d'ailleurs toujours
en pleine évolution mardi soir à la
mairie de voisin lebretonneux une table
ronde comme vous le voyez réunissant des
acteurs importants du projet était
organisé nous en avons profité pour en
savoir plus sur le cluster qui s'étend
sur 49 communes de don l'agglomération
de cquentin en Yveline regardez ce
premier entretien réalisé avec Dominique
Vernet le président de la fondation de
coopération scientifique du campus
universitaire de Paris
Saclay nous sommes avec Dominique Vernet
président de la fondation de la
coopération scientifique du Campus Paris
sacly bonjour bonjour alors tout d'abord
cette table ronde a lieu à l'occasion
d'un bilan pouvez-vous m'en dire un
petit peu plus sur le projet du cluster
aujourd'hui alors projet du cluster
d'abord je dire c'est une une affaire
qui a démarré il y a à peu près 7 à 8
ans l'objectif je dire très clairement
c'est de donner une visibilité à ce
campus Paris- Saclay pour en faire un
des 10 grands campus mondiaux en fait
l'idée c'est de créer au centre de tout
ça une université université qui soit
capable de rivaliser avec Oxford
Cambridge avec
Harvard de façon en fait à à être un
cœur d'innovation et de formation pour
cette zone géographique de l'Ouest
parisien
donc la vocation de l'Université Paris
Sacé de devenir donc une grande
université pour l'instant le campus en
est où que propose-t-il bah le le campus
aujourd'hui il est en train de se bâtir
hein il y a en fait on par pas de rien
on a déjà plus d'une dizaine
d'institutions qui sont localisées là
mais il y en a SEP nouvelles qui vont
arriver certaines de Paris intramuros
d'autres de la banlieu ouest et pour
créer tout un réseau de grandes écoles
d'universités et de centre de recherche
et T l'ensemble de ces établissements
vont se fédérer au sein de ce qu'on
appelle l'Université Paris sacclay et
qui va s'organiser un petit peu comme
l'université britannique en particulier
Oxford et Cambridge où vous avez d'un
côté finalement le la marque ombrelle
qui est Cambridge mais de Cambridge il
faut savoir qu'il y a 56 collèges nous
on n pas 56 collèges on a 19
établissements voilà donc il y a 19
établissements qui travaillent en emble
et qui s'organise pour fonctionner comme
une grande université mondiale alors au
sein de ce campus de cette université
qu'est-ce que va apporter le le cluster
quelle plusvalue va-til avorter le
cluster c'est ce qui a à côté le cluster
c'est en fait ce qui est composé par
l'Université Paris saclé qui est au
centre avec toutes les réseaux
d'entreprises et puis toutes les
associations qui vont permettre de
mettre en réseau l'ensemble de ces
acteurs voilà donc le cluster c'est ça
c'est des grandes entreprises des
petites entreprises des centres de
recherche des centres de formation et
des investisseurs et aussi des
pépinières d'entreprise et aussi des
incubateurs voilà c'est cet ensemble
bouillonnant le mot clé là-dedans c'est
innovation c'est le fonctionnement
réseau alors il y a une volonté de créer
une vraie synergie entre les entreprises
et le comp plus c'est ça voilà
exactement parce qu'en fait la forme
Bonnaire d'innovation c'est ce qu'on
appelle innovation ouverte tu voulez par
contraste avec ce qui se passait
autrefois dans lequel les entreprises
étaient jalouses de leur secret et
concoctai leur secret en quelque sorte
leurs produits dans le dans un splendide
isolement là on voit bien que c'est
c'est plus possible parce que quand on
voit l'accroissement considérable des
connaissances la complexité des
technologies bien vous prenez par
exemple un téléphone portable vous avez
un téléphone portable quand vous
regardez l'ensemble des technologies
qu'il y a là-dedans ce sont des dizaines
de milliers d'ingénieurs qui ont
contribué à réaliser ce produit et donc
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui l'innovation
les nouveaux produits c'est quoi c'est
finalement le le fait de savoir faire
travailler ensemble un grand nombre d'
acteur et finalement mais il faut qu'il
y ait quelqu'un qui ait la vision c'est
le cas des grandes entreprises il y a
d'autres entreprises qui vont des
fournisseurs de technologies
généralement c'est des des entreprises
un peu plus petites et puis a ceux qui
amènent la science et la recherche et
puis ça mène aussi des gens formés des
techniciens des ingénieurs des
chercheurs voilà il y a une volonté un
petit peu de pousser les étudiants
peut-être à devenir créateur
d'entreprise oui alors ça c'est un point
très très important moi je fais pas
beaucoup de distinction entre innovateur
et entrepreneur un innovateur c'est
quelqu'un qui a envie d'entreprendre qui
a des idées et puis qui a la force en
lui pour y arriver hein il y a la
comme on dit dans le sport c'est un peu
la même chose que dans le sport et
effectivement l'idée qu'on a poussé
maintenant c'est de faire en sorte que
ce soit les étudiants qui soient la
force d'entrepreneuriat pourquoi les
étudiants dans le fond parce qu'ils ont
rien à perdre ils sont tout jeunes ils
ont encore la foi ils sont pas installés
donc bah ils ont toute la recette pour
pour prendre des risques et
effectivement ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
les aide à prendre ces risques de
manière calculée et leur rôle c'est
aussi enfin ils doivent être accompagnés
par des chercheurs par leurs professeurs
de qui amènent la compétence si vous
voulez et puis les entreprises peuvent
amener aussi une autre forme de
compétence qui est compéten de terrain
qu en particulier tout ce qui est
business plan et tout ça les entreprises
le font bien parce que elles ont
l'habitude voilà donc c'est cette c'est
l'articulation entre ces entrepreneurs
étudiants et puis tout un écosystème
autour de qui va les aider à réussir
finalement on sa que c'est difficile
aujourd'hui d'être chef d'entreprise on
voit tous les jours est-ce que du coup
pour les étudiants voilà qui ne sont pas
trop acclimatés justement au mon c'est
pas trop difficile bien sûr c'est
difficile d'ê entrepreneur mais d'abord
il y a une la loi la loi crée un statut
d'étudiant entrepreneur et ça c'est un
point important parce que quand un
étudiant qui a une idée arrête ses
études pour mettre en uvre cette idée
faire une entreprise il était plus
couvert par la sécurité soci par tout un
ensemble de prestations aujourd'hui la
ministre je fazo a décidé de mettre en
place ce statut d'étudiant entrepreneur
et ça c'est une très bonne initiative et
par ailleurs chaque école maintenant et
même l'université développe en fait des
cursus et en fait ce qu'on a fait sur le
plateau de sa à travers une initiative
qu'on appelle pôle entrepreneuriat
innovation Paris Sacé c'est de mettre
tout le monde en réseau avec les
chambres de commerces et d'industrie
avec avec les acteurs
économiques de façon finalement ben à ce
que chacun amène à ses étudiants ben de
la compétence voilà l' Université de
Paris sa-clin accueille ses étudiants en
septembre 2015 quelles sont les
perspectives un petit peu d'avenir
est-ce que vous pouvez m'en dire un peu
plus et bien voilà ce qu'on espère c'est
que ce diplôme Université Paris SACL que
soit le master les doctorats puis après
ça va être les licences ce qu'on veut
c'est que ce diplôme Université Paris
saacé il est de la valeur et qu'il soit
comparable à un diplôme de doctorat à
Oxford à Cambridge ou mit ou ailleurs
voilà donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est ça
c'est que ils aent un diplôme dont ils
soient fiers et qu' leur ouvre des
portes et qui soit une sorte de point
important de démarrage dans la vie on
sait que de toute façon avec l'évolution
technique ça sera pas suffisant il
faudra que régulièrement il viennent
mais ce qu'on souhaite c'est qu'il
reviennent sur le campus à parce que vu
la multiplicité compétent je suis sûr
qu'il y aura des réponses à toutes leur
questions très bien merci Domini
ver notre deè entretien réalisé avec
Laurent Le Gendre le président de Delta
Sky 50 ans en Iline nous avons évoqué
avec lui les conséquences et les impacts
du cluster sur les entreprises du
territoire regardez nous sommes avec
Laurent leendre le président de Delta
Sky 50evin l'association regroupant les
grandes entreprise de 50 ans yeline
pouvez-vous nous expliquer les
conséquences de ce cluster sur les
grandes entreprises et les petites de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yveline ah
alors le cluster c'est un un projet
assez vaste qui s'inscrit dans le dans
le grand projet de Paris Saclay et qui
euh va avoir des impacts sur le
territoire en matière
d'industrialisation le projet Paris
sacly a très connu pour son son aspect
onien sur sacclay avec le regroupement
de centre de recherche qu'il soit public
ou privé sur
50 ans en Yveline il va y avoir un
prolongement avec les applications
industrielles des développements qui
vont être faits par les centres de
recherche euh qui seront basés sur les
sones et l'objectif est que on puisse
structurer un peu le le développement
industriel de Saint-Quentin qu'on trouve
un renouveau sur les 20 dernières années
ce sont essentiellement les grandes
entreprises qui se sont implantées à
saquentin qui ont peut-être un peu
saturé d'ailleurs la possibilité puce
que encore quelques-unes viennent de
s'implanter comme safranc qui va
installer son tout près d'ici son centre
de
recherche mais autour de ces grandes
entreprises il va falloir fédérer des
acteurs plus petits qui vont venir se
développer autour de l'activité que va
fournir ces grand hneur d'ordre comment
les entreprises appréhendent-elles donc
la la venue le le développement de ce
cluster quelles opportunités cela
pourra-t-il leur apporter ah alors c'est
essentiel oui parce que une grande
entreprise elle ne vit pas par elle-même
seule elle a besoin de fournisseur elle
a besoin de sous-traitants elle a besoin
de consultant
elle a besoin de tout un écosystème et
qui fait qu'elle va être plus efficace
et si cet écosystème est structuré ça va
renforcer ce sa sa réactivité et c'est
sa propre efficacité est-ce que
justement ce cluster est essentiel pour
elle et pour leur développement l'idée
de de structurer des développements
autour de choses qui sont déjà
existantes qui se sont créé pas
complètement au hasard non plus si on
prend le secteur de l'aéronautique que
je connais bien la région parisienne est
la première région aéronautique de
France on pense naturellement à Toulouse
mais au niveau de la densité d'emploi la
région Île-de-France est devant la
région toulousaine en matière
d'aéronautique et une grosse partie de
ces acteurs aéronautiques se retrouvent
sur 51 Newlin donc on va assister
naturellement à une continuité du
développement de cette activité
aéronautique qui est encore une activité
en progrès et qui est en progrès assez
constant et qui va continuer à se dév
développer dans les années à venir à
l'international est-ce que cela va
pousser des entreprises à s'installer
ici ou peut-être à développer leur
activité sur le territoire de 50 ans en
niveline oui bien sûr nos entreprises ne
travaillent pas qu'avec des acteurs
français évidemment on prend tous les
grands acteurs de de l'aéronautique ils
ont tous une dimension internationale et
font la majeure partie de leur chiffre
d'affaires à l'export et ils travaillent
aussi avec des partenaires qui qui qui
sont des partenaires étrangers qui
peuvent aussi venir se se se développer
sur le territoire français pour des
besoins répondre à des besoins
industriels le pôle de Paris saint-celin
a l'ambition de se positionner parmi les
cinq premers mondiaux selon vous est-ce
réalisable pourquoi pas osons la
France et nous revenons sur le le sujet
du campus universitaire avec le chiffre
de la semaine c'est tout de
suite 2,2 milliards d'euros c'est la
somme qui va être investie dans le
campus d'ici 2 20 pour rappel il reste
1,3 million de mètr carrés à construire
sur le campus qui accueille en 2014 plus
de 48000 étudiants ce campus regroupe
déjà 10 % des effectifs de la recherche
en France dont 20 % dans le domaine de
la physique et de l'énergie l'état
engage dans ce projet un effort
financier sans précédent je vous propose
maintenant de découvrir avec moi
l'entreprise de la
semaine plus que quelques jours avant
que petits et grands ne découvrent leurs
cadeau de Noël à cette occasion cette
semaine nous avons décidé de vous faire
découvrir ou redécouvrir une entreprise
de jeux de société mais pas n'importe
laquelle à se Moder le numéro 1 français
du jeu de société l'entreprise est basée
à Guy encour et elle ne cesse de se
développer comme vous allez le découvrir
dans ce reportage réalisé avec Elodie
moine et Romain
ruspini des jeux de société à ne plus
savoir quoi en faire nous ne sommes pas
dans une succursale de l'atelier du Père
Noël mais au siège social d'asmodé les
Aventuriers du Rail au tarichaud la
guerre des œufs double Jungle Speed ou
encore élixir ils sont tous édités par
cette entreprise une PME yvelinoise
devenue en quelques années le numéro 1
français des jeux de société elle
distribue dans les magasins spécialisés
les jeux qu'elle conçoit ainsi que ceux
de 36 éditeurs quand on rencontre des
auteurs ou des studios qui développe des
jeux où il y a juste une idée on va les
accompagner en fait pour développer ce
jeu et pour pouvoir lancer le jeu sur
marché et qu'on va retrouver le jeu dans
le dans les commerces donc on va tout
développer on va être en contact avec
les auteurs avec des designers des
graphistes le jeu de société dernier
rempart contre les écrans résiste au
jeux vidéo et même à la crise la PME l'a
bien compris et elle ne s'adresse plus
seulement aux enfants la grosse tendance
ça reste bien évidemment les jeux qu'on
appelle Party Game c'est des jeux un peu
d'apéro qu'on joue entre adules c'est
jeux on Smart des jeux fun conviviaux
qui sont rapides donc les les meilleurs
exemple c'est times up c'est Jungle
Speed c'est double double c'est 700000
exemplaires vendus par an la meilleure
vente de l'entreprise né en 1995 dans
les Yvelines elle s'est d'abord installé
à voisin le Bretonneux avant d'investir
ses locaux de guilloncour au début ils
étaient h aujourd'hui la société emploie
plus de 200 salariés chaque année il
lance près de 200 nouveautés sur le
marché du jeu de société un défi de
taille le secteur est soumis à de
nombreuses contraintes il y a certains
plastiques qu'on appelle le PS qui passe
pas l' normme euh
le PS passe certaines normes mais pas
toutes en fait ça dépend de sa
composition donc on est obligé de faire
des tests pour vérifier que ça passe
bien c'est ce qu'on demande à la base au
fournisseurs mais maintenant en fait on
vérifie systématiquement derrière que ça
passe bien les tests on nous dirige
aussi vers des matières plus écolos
maintenant des normes qui n'entravent
pas son développement asmodé a ouvert 8
filiales à travers le monde en 2013
l'entreprise est passée numéro 1 des jeu
de société en France devant le géant
américain Hasbro un succès en partie dû
à son identité française
il y a une spécifalité dans la création
française on y a vraiment une french
touch avec beaucoup d'auteurs français
qui ont un style particulier un style de
de de création et une mécanique de jeu
et il y a un style d'édition française
qui est très léché avec beaucoup de
qualité sur le matériel la French Touch
das modé s'exporte dans près de 44 pays
dans le monde elle représente 34 % des
parts de marché sur le segment du jeu
pour la période de janvier à mai 2014
mais l'entreprise ne prend pas la grosse
tête et ne perd pas de vue son activité
essentielle il y a des gens qui jouent
leur plaisir souvent ils jouent le midi
ils prennent des il jouent enfin il y a
beaucoup de gens qui font ça et après
sinon il y a des séances de jeux qui
sont des vraies séances de test où on
joue au jeu pour le décortiquer ça on
fait ça plutôt le vendredi en principe
grâce à son nouvel actionnaire
l'Américain eurazo a modé a racheté le
groupe Days of Wonder et Fantasy Flight
Games l'entreprise estime à 200 million
d'euros son chiffre d'affaires pour
cette année pour ces grands enfants la
partie est loin d'être
finie
c'est déjà la fin de notre émission la
dernière de cette année 2014 merci de
nous avoir suivi je vous donne donc
rendez-vous l'année prochaine le 8
janvier exactement pour le premier
filcho de l'année 2015 il ne me reste
plus qu'à vous souhaiter d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année je vous souhaite
une très bonne
soirée